the Star Wars Battlefront beta is late
that game is head just about a month
away november seventeenth and we've got
the whole crew here Justin hey walls
Aaron Samson Robert handlery you're all
here to talk about the Star Wars
battlefield beta mostly these two though
because you guys went playing in all
morning yeah Aaron Samson first of all
what's in this Bay that where can you
get it what platform is walking you
played it's by its I think it's gonna be
open in two days it's just by invite
right now I think anybody who wants is
gonna be able to get in on the 8th cool
it includes Hoth and Walker assault mode
and involves Sullust drop zone which is
like kind team deathmatch king of the
hill and there is coop right yeah they
also they also have the attack slump in
there but no one plays back well the
game when you start the beta the game
very clearly tells you you don't have
any gear go get gear before you play
these other modes okay they want you to
go experience the two other modes before
walkers and it's at pc and ps4 you guys
are playing in the office right now
right yeah is there an xbox one bait as
well we know haven't gotten codes for
yet look I think so oh I don't know time
eventually yeah okay so what's most
important than is what you guys think
about it and there's been a lot of chat
in the office this morning about it
seems to be waxing and waning Aaron
first of all what do you think your mess
about 50 what do you think about
battlefront as a as a guy who plays a
lot of multiplayer shooters this thing
doesn't seem targeted at me it's like I
feel like the advertising was targeted
at me but it's a very very simple very
casual game like it's got dead simple
unlocks most of the abilities you can
get in like a morning and they don't do
like all that of different things and
each mode is just really straightforward
so like yeah its mechanics are solid but
in terms of gameplay itself I I'm are
kind of already bored yeah most
important that it gets the the basics
that it gets the gameplay down and you
can add like this is the beta you're
gonna layer on the more difficult stuff
that's what we're hoping for I think
that's why you know initial kickoff
today was a little wee little boring was
because it's just it's just the same
stuff because you said
I mean rebels and imperials start off or
have the same weapon okay and so it's
like you're firing I mean I guess Aaron
says there's kind of like an active
reload with recharging but it's there
isn't really a reload you just you know
finding a corridor you're just try one
gym is saying web there's no like
different classes or weapon loadouts
right from the start no class yeah
there's no classes you can buy the
different weapon loadouts it has a
little bit of a card system which is
just your abilities and there's some
customization to it but I don't know
like I feel like there's there's a thing
where they're solving problems they
created like the game has a sniper rifle
and like why do you need a sniper rifle
in battlefront you know the game has
x-wings & Tie Fighters but like that's
just solving the Walker assault mode
problem like the original movie right it
was just it was snowspeeders verse
Walker's that was cool it was fun right
but then like so the instant you had
guys on the ground you had those yeah
because you're the assault on the hoff
base itself yet guys defending the base
but it feels like it's kind of expanding
that outing melding them in a way maybe
that's not as true to the movie but that
aside looking how's that same problem of
the battlefield 3 had where the aerial
fights were just completely disconnected
from what was happening on the ground
and this I mean I think Ben go battle 3
4 like it's funny like coming in I
really uh was just pissed off with
ariel's and the aerial game in this in
battle fun entirely I was like really
upset first off I couldn't even look at
my joystick get the hell out of here
yeah that's for PC I mean that was a
huge thing for me maybe it's you know
this is just beta of course but just now
a couple hours ago I was playing and I
was an a-wing and I started to get some
kills for the first time aerial kills
you know you watch all the footage all
you see is this just people crashing
because the aerial game is just too
freakin fast it needs to be slowed down
drastically the maps don't seem that big
seer they're not beating over everything
right right there's just a constant rain
of like TIE fighters and aliens and
actually falling out of this guy right
maybe i will just found that to be
really effective at killing ok so i only
looks and sounds cool though that's for
sure like I will be I'm at the point now
where like I dislike the air game so
much i'll be running up a trench and
i'll see you like an x-wing icon at all
yes
around it try to know who else reverse
back a little bit know and we can icon
okay now back guys we we were talking
about earlier oh you just walk over and
you immediately get in there is an
initiation how does it cool down yeah
all right so no you have to initiate to
pick up and then you turn so it's not
like in other Battlefield games not to
pick up constantly comparing it but just
what I know other battle fig aims where
Jets spawn vehicle spawn and you go to
it and you get in the jet and there you
go up and if you die the chances are you
can respawn back close to the jet and
starting us in this one you like yes no
since in this you pick up icons and
randomly appear and yeah it's like mario
kart cuz why not well i would say yes
and no I it there's a cool down so like
there were times where I was in a TIE
fighter crashed or died however you want
to say and I was able to respond and go
back that same location and pick up the
same icon again okay so there is that
sometimes but the thing about hof in the
walker salt is that it's never changing
mat you're following the walkers to the
final destination so things do change
and you know for instance and then on
the rebel side like I've got me a min
once and I never saw that icon again but
that I'm so strange because then
presumably like one of the things in the
o Balthasar games is the people who
wanted to fly those Jets coach no no
they went to go and find them and get
them whereas in this one it seems like
if you're just running around you could
you just wander into one so then the
people who are getting those flying
ships aren't necessarily having wants to
get see playing yeah and so it gets even
more confusing when you have the hero
system at it in because the heroes are
not skill-based they're also like mario
kart coin pickups so you can just pick
up something in your theater they rotate
around so you never know where they're
gonna be so you just run you grab when
it's like oh I can be Darth Vader and
then it teleports you somewhere random
on the map oh right okay so it's not
even like you can't just pop it and then
be like I'm gonna charge through these
stormtroopers you get teleported then
you gotta go figure out where the storm
troopers went hmm and like so like okay
like the footage there too there's
things that happen like there was our
faith are doing CEO stated what it took
a nice beta man get tired so two heroes
meet in the middle of the field right
they can lock lightsabers and there was
like this video about how great that is
but like if you think that through those
logical conclusion
if two heroes are locked together in
like a QTE they're all just gonna get
shot in the back all right yeah like
they're just gonna be stuck and they're
gonna get grenade it so like yeah here's
the heroes could be completely removed
so that's the one thing I want to see
some people who were listening could say
that oh like a lot of these issues are
like nitpicky like it's the way that
mechanic works or hair dye feels but the
fact that you guys are like fans of
these types of games fans of Star Wars
and you're not feeling impassioned and
you're not thinking that this is like a
great game that to me speaks volumes
like you're a master file to start wars
and this just doesn't do it for you like
you all you wanted to but it doesn't
yeah that's why I'm like kind of like so
sad is that one the more I play them
like god this is great man a bunch of
that thai fighter yeah yeah keep going
on playa and play I mean I'm getting
some of that and like again I was
playing as a TIE fighter and I was
finally getting some kills you know
there's a whole thing where you know as
a rebel you you get the uplinks to allow
y-wings to come in to basically use the
ion cannon on the 8080 so now they can
be hit by ground fire and I'll stop I
know shut up stop stop I'm onto
something here I'm with you it was kind
of cool because I was stopping the
y-wings from hat like I was shooting him
down and I was I felt like that was
finally useful because you know as we
were saying earlier like what the hell
are these ships doing up there yeah but
the issue is that the white ones come so
quick that it's like the aerial game is
just slow them down like why was like oh
that's why we oh he's out all right well
I didn't do anything they're like well
that's what those ships are then that
makes sense it just doesn't make sense
for this map like those are aerial
dogfighters right you could still slow
down I don't know but yes it's just as
it as initial kickoff for this beta yeah
it's a little disheartening and it's not
really and you say beta like you've been
through the mill on this like so many
times the final games like when it's a
beta a month before the game come to
it's not a bad mo yeah like rainbow is
funny i just played Rainbow six siege
they called that a beta that was like an
alpha like they brought it were still
like legitimately working out bugs this
is clearly just a demo to get people in
and to be fair I've been talking to
people in this office who are not huge
shooter fans and like we're willing to
let Star Wars Canon
just go out the window yeah and they
enjoy this game because like I don't
know that they're not that twitchy of a
person it has a generous aim assist it
has very simple mechanics where so I
think that's their audience like I think
their audience are people who are not
huge shooter fan totally agree there the
audience are people who are excited
about this upcoming movie star what
exactly right coming up in December I
disagree that's crazy i know i think i
think that's not ours fan I've always
been a huge Star Wars fan and that's why
when I see like Return of the Jedi like
Luke running across the Hoss it pisses
me off it's like what did you just put
him in the right clothes like was it was
it that hole that was that's the
argument and put him in the right
clothes argument was that he wasn't a
Jedi on Hawk man you still learning
railing this one back in OC I did an
interview with the devs recently reason
that they did I read it the reason they
did return the Jedi Luke what was
because they wanted a Jedi who's more
powerful like this was the version that
we saw but a woman because some like 12
year old kids gonna get the power up and
then gonna be the Jedi so it's not gonna
be that promise well like NYU Luke
Skywalker it sounds like they made the
most like this feels like the like a
nerf arena blast of first-person
shooters it's like this very basic
version it's like it's for mainstream
gamers or think yes that audience that
audience is probably out there like
they're gonna like it the audience you
want to take down a walker with an ipad
version of a quick time events like when
you put the tow hook on it's like i did
you really there the QTE like for some
reason you're already flying it you
can't just keep flying in circles did
you know this is all this so in the
snowspeeder you get to of course he's
the iconic harpoon cable and Dougal and
do the laps around the legs I've seen it
in in like oh not like Oh dimensions
I've seen today I mean in every shadow
the upper about the other toys to life
thing disney infinity yeah it's like in
every star wars game right by Lowell so
yeah I thought well yeah you gotta
snowspeeder you got a walker it's gonna
happen and in this case it's pretty bad
all it is is you get you approach the
walker in the snow speeder you get the
prompt you hit whatever button and all
it is is now a game a mini
game of keeping the snowspeeder reticule
in a grey box and it fights you on it
like not and not all around the box gets
up and down so yeah yeah get in there
and that's it and that's all it is and
then it's a little smaller oh this is
your this is tough so you want the
version where you're actually driving
around but you're already you're already
flying it like you fly it and then you
initiate the tow cable yeah and rather
than just keep flying one-handed thing
come on that was much be the hardest
thing never shall the Empire like doing
that like that was tough it sounds like
it they've just trimmed this game down
to its like bare escentuals yes cover
all star wars basis it's a very very
simple game and again like if they
weren't putting the full price on it and
if they weren't putting the like the
premium concept on top of it like I
would be cool with that like I've seen
plenty of games recently where I feel
like you just sold it that it's like $40
$45 like you have a much larger audience
but would have lower expectations like
they wouldn't be disappointed that you
cut out you know space battles or
galactic conquest or no I mean it's not
really had a campaign but yeah the [ __ ]
you didn't put one in yeah but like
again like the full price like premium
it's just it's so simple alright so what
is curious when you're low on health
does it regenerate automatically or do
you have to find a tauntaun kiloton
Corliss yeah warm up all right those are
patience of a story about from Justin
thank you so much thank you cash game
yes of course I rob thank you so much
going on oh thank you man sad to be more
coverage i'm assuming on gamespot during
the week from both you guys on Star Wars
but in the meantime if you got a chance
to hop in the open beta yourself I let
us know what you think in the comments
below are you excited does this scratch
your Star Wars hitch doesn't scratch
your battlefield itch scratch is
something let us know in the comments
below